So John, you're from Minnesota. Right?
约翰，你是明尼苏达人，对吧？
I am from Minnesota.
我是明尼苏达人。
John Biewen's a public radio guy, makes documentaries. And he says growing up in Minnesota, there was a way that people usually talked about the history of the state.
约翰·比文（John Biewen）是一名公共广播电台的工作人员，从事纪录片制作。他说，在明尼苏达州长大的过程中，人们谈论该州历史的方式通常只有一种。
And it's often told in a kind of light and self-deprecating way that northern Europeans came over, and they staggered out onto the tundra and said, oh, this reminds us of home. And they didn't know enough to keep going to some more pleasant place. And so they built their sod huts and laid out their farms.
这种叙事通常带有一种轻松且自嘲的色彩：北欧移民漂洋过海，步履蹒跚地走到苔原上，感叹这里很像家乡。他们因为不知道要继续前行去更宜居的地方，于是就在这里搭建了泥屋，开垦了农田。
Sometimes there's an oh, by the way, Indians were here when we got here.
有时还会顺便提一句：我们到这里时，印第安人就在这儿了。
It's either an afterthought or it doesn't come up at all. And there was always a sense, too, growing up in a place like southern Minnesota, that nothing had ever happened there.
这要么是一个事后的补充，要么根本就不会被提起。而且在明尼苏达州南部这样的地方长大，总有一种感觉：那里从来没发生过什么大事。
Which, John points out, is completely weird. Southern Minnesota-- he's learned since he grew up there-- was the location of one of the major wars with the Plains Indians, the US-Dakota War. It happened during the same period as the Civil War.
约翰指出，这种感觉非常奇怪。他长大后才了解到，明尼苏达州南部曾是与平原印第安人爆发重大战争的地方，即美洲达科他战争（US-Dakota War）。这场战争发生的时间与美国南北战争时期重叠。
More people died in that war than died at Little Big Horn or Wounded Knee. In fact, John's own hometown-- Mankato-- was the site of the largest mass execution in US history of Dakota warriors. 38 of them were hanged by the order of Abraham Lincoln, a little more than 150 years ago, the day after Christmas, 1862.
在那场战争中丧生的人数比小大角战役（Little Big Horn）或伤膝河大屠杀（Wounded Knee）还要多。事实上，约翰的家乡曼卡托（Mankato）正是美国历史上最大规模处决达科他勇士的地点。约150年前的1862年圣诞节后一天，亚伯拉罕·林肯下令将38名达科他族人处以绞刑。
And the place where that hanging happened, it's right in the heart of downtown. I would've hung out at the mall not far from there, a few blocks down the street. I would have ridden past that spot on my way to Pizza Hut with my buddies, who knows how many times. And never-- it just never-- I didn't hear about it.
那场绞刑发生的地点就在市中心。我以前经常在离那儿不远的商场闲逛，离那儿也就几个街区。我和朋友去必胜客的路上，不知道骑车经过那个地方多少次了。但从来……真的从来没有……我根本没听说过这件事。
He says he doesn't remember it being taught in school or being mentioned at all his entire childhood by anybody, even though this war is arguably the biggest event in the state's history. It paved the way for Minnesota to become the place it is today, led directly to all the Dakota being kicked off their own land and expelled from the state under conditions that killed hundreds of them.
他说，他不记得学校教过这段历史，整个童年时期也没有人提起过，尽管这场战争可以说是该州历史上最大的事件。它为明尼苏达州成为今天的样子铺平了道路，并直接导致所有达科他族人被赶出自己的土地，被迫离开该州，而这些被迫迁移的条件导致数百人死亡。
And if anybody should have heard about it, it should have been me. My parents worked on the McGovern campaign. They admired Martin Luther King. My dad was a high school English teacher who taught To Kill a Mockingbird. And every Sidney Poitier movie that came on TV, they would sit us down and watch it. And I was raised to have a social-- look, I went on to be a public radio reporter.
如果说有谁应该听说过这件事，那个人应该是我。我的父母曾在麦戈文（McGovern）竞选团队工作。他们崇拜马丁·路德·金。我父亲是一名高中英语老师，曾教授《杀死一只知更鸟》。电视上每放一部西德尼·波蒂埃（Sidney Poitier）的电影，他们都会让我们坐下来一起看。我从小就被培养得很有社会意识——听着，我后来还成了公共广播电台的记者。
I was going to say. Really, how did you end up in public broadcasting?
我正想说。真的，你是怎么进入公共广播行业的？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was raised to be aware of the nation's racial injustices. It's just that they all happened someplace else, not in Minnesota.
我从小就被教育要关注国内的种族不公。只不过，他们认为这些事都发生在其他地方，而不是明尼苏达州。
For the last 17 years, John's lived down south, in North Carolina. And he says that at some point the contrast in how people saw their own history down south really hit him.
过去17年里，约翰一直住在南方，即北卡罗来纳州。他说，在某个时刻，南方人看待自身历史的方式与明尼苏达形成的鲜明对比真正触动了他。
Not that people down south are sitting around reminiscing about Stonewall Jackson all day long. I mean, that's really not the case. But there is a general and pervasive understanding in the South that something very big happened in the 1860s that shaped the place right up to the present. And that's what's missing in Minnesota.
并不是说南方人整天围坐在一起回忆石墙杰克逊（Stonewall Jackson）。我的意思是，事实并非如此。但在南方，人们普遍有一种深入骨髓的共识，即1860年代发生了一件大事，塑造了该地直至今日的面貌。而这正是明尼苏达所缺失的。
So a while back John Biewen started traveling around the state with two questions-- first, what exactly happened back in 1862? And, second--
所以前阵子，约翰·比文带着两个问题开始在州内各地奔走——首先，1862年到底发生了什么？其次——
Why don't we talk about it? Why haven't we internalized this story in Minnesota into our understanding of the place?
为什么我们不谈论它？为什么我们在明尼苏达州还没有将这个故事内化为我们对这片土地的认知？
And so, today, the week after Thanksgiving, we bring you this story of Indians and settlers. I found so many of the details of what John learned to be completely surprising. Maybe you will too. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Stay with us.
所以，今天，在感恩节过后的这一周，我们为您带来这个关于印第安人和定居者的故事。我发现约翰学到的许多细节都非常令人震惊。也许你也会有同感。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life）。请继续收听。
So now I turn things over to John Biewen.
现在，我把话筒交给约翰·比文。
In setting out to understand what happened in southern Minnesota in 1862, I called up Gwen Westerman. She agreed to spend a few days with me driving around the state to the spots where it all occurred, so I could tell the story here on the radio.
为了弄清楚1862年明尼苏达州南部到底发生了什么，我联系了格温·韦斯特曼（Gwen Westerman）。她答应陪我花几天时间开车走遍全州，探访事情发生的地方，这样我就能在广播里讲述这个故事。
We meet up in Mankato. I grew up there but haven't lived there for 30 years. She's lived and taught there for the last 20 years.
我们在曼卡托碰面。我在那儿长大，但已经30年没住在那儿了。而她在过去20年里一直住在那儿并任教。
More people probably know about the town of Mankato than realize it.
比起意识到这个地方的人，可能更多人知道曼卡托这个城镇的名字。
That's us, in Gwen's SUV.
这是我们，在格温的SUV里。
Because in the television series Little House On The Prairie, the Ingalls family lived in Walnut Grove. And whenever Ma and Pa wanted to get away from the kids, they came to Mankato.
因为在电视剧《草原小屋》（Little House On The Prairie）中，英格尔斯（Ingalls）一家住在核桃林（Walnut Grove）。每当马和帕想避开孩子们时，他们就会去曼卡托。
Gwen's an English professor at Minnesota State University in Mankato and a member of the Dakota tribe. She's in her 50s like me. She grew up in Kansas, part of the Dakota diaspora. A lot of her family was banished from Minnesota after the 1862 war-- not that she's always known that herself.
格温是曼卡托明尼苏达州立大学的英语教授，也是达科他部落的一员。她和我一样50多岁。她在堪萨斯州长大，是达科他流散群体的一部分。她的许多家人在1862年战争后被驱逐出明尼苏达州——并不是她一直都知道这一点。
See, I grew up in Mankato, a white kid knowing next to nothing about the bloody history that happened beneath my feet. Gwen got a teaching job and moved to Mankato, also knowing nothing about that history. She found out later that some older people in her family did know.
看，我在曼卡托长大，作为一个白人孩子，对脚下发生的血腥历史几乎一无所知。格温后来得到了教职搬到曼卡托时，也对这段历史一无所知。她后来发现，她家里的长辈其实是知道的。
Then, when I took the job here at MSU, my father and my uncle would say, well, we'll see how long you last there. But they never did explain why they had questions about whether I would stay here or not.
后来，当我接手了州立大学的工作时，我父亲和我叔叔会说，嗯，看看你能在那儿待多久。但他们从来没有解释过为什么他们会怀疑我是否能在那里待下去。
So, December 26, 1993, I had a friend who worked at the university. She said, there are Indians coming. She was also Indian. She said, there are Indians coming. Let's go see what they're doing.
1993年12月26日，我有个朋友在大学工作。她说，有印第安人要来了。她自己也是印第安人。她说，有印第安人要来了。我们去看看他们在做什么。
That's all she said?
她只说了这么多？
That's all she said. So I said, OK. She came and picked me up.
她只说了这么多。我说，好的。她开车来接我。
Gwen didn't know it, but she and her friend Kimberly were going to see the annual ceremony for the Dakota warriors who were hanged in the town square in 1862.
格温当时不知道，她和朋友金伯利（Kimberly）正要去参加一年一度的纪念仪式，悼念1862年在市政广场被绞死的达科他勇士。
They arrived late for the ceremony and stood in the back for the prayers and songs. They still didn't know what the event was about. And then it was over.
她们赶到仪式现场时已经晚了，站在后面听祈祷和歌唱。她们当时仍然不知道这个活动是关于什么的。然后仪式就结束了。
Kimberly and I got back in the car and she was driving. And she started to pull around the corner of the building. And I don't know if your parents drove fast on back country roads when you were small, up and down the hills.
我和金伯利回到车上，由她开车。她开始绕过大楼的拐角。我不知道你小时候父母在乡间小路上开车快不快，是不是也会上坡下坡。
We used to love it when my parents would do that because you'd go over the top of the hill and then your stomach would kind of come up. But as we rounded the corner of the building, my stomach came up just like that. And I started to sob.
我们以前很喜欢父母那样开车，因为当你越过山顶时，胃会有一种向上的感觉。但当我们转过大楼拐角时，我的胃就是那种感觉。然后我开始啜泣。
And Kimberly stopped the car and said, what's wrong? What's wrong? And I told her I had no idea what was wrong. It was incredible sadness. I didn't really say anything to anybody about that until a few days later when I called my uncle and explained to him what had happened.
金伯利停下车问我，你怎么了？出什么事了？我告诉她我不知道自己怎么了。那是一种难以置信的悲伤。直到几天后我给叔叔打电话，向他解释了发生的事情，我才真正跟别人提起过。
After I finished my story, he was quiet for a long time. Then he finally said, well, my girl, you're connected to that place. You are physically and spiritually connected to that place.
听完我的叙述，他沉默了很久。最后他说，孩子，你和那个地方是有联系的。你在身体上和精神上都与那个地方相连。
Come on.
得了吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That's crazy.
这太疯狂了。
Yeah, so I don't-- how do you explain it? I didn't know what had happened here.
是啊，所以我不知道……你该怎么解释呢？我根本不知道这里发生过什么。
After that, she learned all about it-- how the Dakota chief who led the uprising in 1862-- Little Crow-- was the brother of her great-great-great-great-grandmother. Another relative, Mazamani, was killed in the last battle of the war. Now she is so steeped in it, she co-wrote a book about the history of the Dakota people in Minnesota.
在那之后，她了解了一切——1862年领导起义的达科他酋长小乌鸦（Little Crow），竟然是她高祖母的兄弟。另一位亲戚马扎马尼（Mazamani）在战争的最后一场战役中牺牲了。现在她对这段历史钻研极深，甚至还参与合写了一本关于明尼苏达州达科他民族历史的书。
The sign is faded-- "Historic site to the right."
牌子已经褪色了——“右转即是历史遗址”。
On a gravel farm road an hour and a half from Mankato, there's an oddly placed historic marker.
在距离曼卡托一个半小时路程的一条碎石农场公路上，有一个位置奇怪的历史标记。
Here?
在这儿？
To find it, you have to pull into somebody's driveway. The yard is sheltered by pine trees.
要找到它，你得开进某人的私人车道。院子里种着几棵松树作为遮蔽。
We've driven on to a farm site with a classic, weathered red barn and outbuildings, a small house that looks newer, complete with an American flag and a satellite dish.
我们开进了一个农场遗址，那里有一座经典的风化红谷仓和附属建筑，还有一栋看起来比较新的小屋，上面挂着美国国旗，装着卫星天线。
And then, right in the middle of their yard, is a marble monument.
然后，就在他们院子正中央，立着一座大理石纪念碑。
It's a short obelisk etched with the names of five white settlers who were killed here by Dakota men in August of 1862. This was the incident that started the US-Dakota War. Gwen reads a steel plaque that was put up in the 1960s--
那是一根短方尖碑，上面刻着1862年8月在Acton被达科他族人杀害的五名白人定居者的名字。正是这一事件引发了美洲达科他战争。格温读着1960年代立起的一块钢板铭文——
The Acton Incident-- on a bright Sunday afternoon, August 17, 1862, for young, Sioux hunters, on a spur-of-the-moment dare, decided to prove their bravery by shooting Robinson Jones.
“Acton事件——1862年8月17日，一个晴朗的周日下午，四名苏族猎人一时兴起，决定通过枪杀罗宾逊·琼斯（Robinson Jones）来证明他们的勇敢。”
Stopping at his cabin, they requested liquor and were refused. Then Jones, followed by the seemingly friendly Indians, went to the neighboring Howard Baker cabin, which stood on this site.
他们来到他的小屋，索要酒精被拒。随后琼斯跟着看似友好的印第安人，来到位于此处的邻居霍华德·贝克（Howard Baker）的小屋。
It's hard for me to picture the story this plaque tells. It says the Dakotas and the white man went to a neighbor's cabin-- right here where the monument is now-- and got into a target-shooting contest. Maybe that's what people did with passing strangers on the frontier in 1862. Then the plaque says the Indians suddenly turned on the whites and shot three men, and two women dead.
我很难想象这块铭文所描述的故事。上面说达科他族人和白人走到邻居的小屋——也就是现在纪念碑所在的位置——进行射击比赛。也许这就是1862年边疆地区的人和路人打交道的方式。然后铭文说，印第安人突然转向白人，开枪打死了三名男子和两名妇女。
The Indians fled south to their village, 40 miles away on the Minnesota River. There, they reported what they had done, and the Sioux chiefs decided to wage an all-out war against the white man.
印第安人逃回了40英里外明尼苏达河边的村庄。在那里，他们报告了自己的所作所为，苏族酋长们决定对白人发动全面战争。
Thus, the unplanned shooting of five settlers here at Acton triggered the bloody Sioux uprising of 1862. They decided to wage an all-out war against the white man.
因此，Acton这五名定居者的意外枪杀事件引发了血腥的苏族起义。他们决定对白人发动全面战争。
You shook your head at that part.
读到那部分时你摇了摇头。
I did. It's as if it were that there was nothing that led up to this. It leaves out so much. But it's a small monument. You can't get everything on there.
是的，我是摇了摇头。这好像在说在此之前没有任何导火索。这漏掉的东西太多了。但这只是一座小纪念碑，你没法把所有内容都写上去。
[CAR DOORS SHUTTING]
[车门关上]
To get some of the story that's not on the sign, Gwen and I drive to a small museum. From the outside, it looks like one of those wayside rest buildings. It sits on a highway 15 miles north of Mankato, just outside the town where I went to college, St. Peter.
为了了解铭文上没有的故事，格温和我开车去了一家小型博物馆。从外面看，它就像路边的休息站建筑。它坐落在距离曼卡托以北15英里的一条高速公路旁，就在我上大学的圣彼得（St. Peter）镇外。
So this is our cleverly called "Intro Room."
这就是我们自诩为“介绍室”的地方。
Ben Leonard's tall and lanky. He directs this museum-- The Traverse des Sioux Treaty Site.
本·伦纳德（Ben Leonard）身材高大瘦削。他管理着这家博物馆——特拉弗斯德苏（Traverse des Sioux）条约遗址。
I've been here since 2004. And, for the record, I'm a 36-year-old white guy from North Carolina.
我从2004年就在这里了。顺便提一下，我是来自北卡罗来纳州的36岁白人。
Really?
真的吗？
Our Carolina connection noted, we have the required conversation about college hoops--
确认了我们的卡罗来纳联系后，我们聊了聊大学篮球这个必谈话题——
At a time when Duke basketball--
在杜克大学篮球队……的时候
Then get down to the reason Gwen and I are here. This museum, with its big, central room of maps and panels, gives the history that led to the 1862 war.
然后切入格温和我来到这里的目的。这个博物馆中央的大房间里摆满了地图和展板，讲述了导致1862年战争的历史。
First, the basics-- the Dakota have lived in Minnesota at least 1,000 years and maybe a lot longer. They vastly outnumbered any Europeans who showed up until the mid-1800s, when white people started flooding in.
首先是基本事实——达科他族人在明尼苏达州至少生活了1000年，甚至更久。在19世纪中叶白人大规模涌入之前，他们的人数远远超过了任何出现的欧洲人。
And you can probably guess what happened next, because it happened all across the country. The country's leaders, going back to the founders, talked bluntly about prying land out of Indian hands. I'd never realized just how bluntly until talking to Ben. On the wall of the museum is a blown-up text from a letter I'd never seen. Thomas Jefferson wrote it in 1803.
你大概能猜到接下来发生了什么，因为这在全国各地都在上演。国家的领导人，从开国元勋开始，就直言不讳地谈论如何从印第安人手中夺取土地。在与本交谈之前，我从未意识到他们说得有多露骨。博物馆墙上挂着一封我从未见过的信的放大文本，是托马斯·杰斐逊（Thomas Jefferson）在1803年写的。
Jefferson basically says, look, we want Indian land. But they're not just going to give it to us. So we have to motivate them to sign treaties. And the way that we do that is going to be to get them into debt.
杰斐逊基本是说，看，我们想要印第安人的土地。但他们不会主动给我们。所以我们必须激励他们签署条约。而我们采取的方法是让他们背上债务。
All right. How did Jefferson really say that?
好的。杰斐逊真的是这么说的吗？
He said it hither-- the quote is here. "To promote the disposition to exchange lands, we shall push our trading houses and be glad to see the good and influential individuals among them run in debt. Because we observe that when these debts get beyond what individuals can pay, they are willing to lop them off by the session of lands." So that's fairly matter-of-fact.
他是这样说的——引文就在这儿。“为了促进土地交换，我们将推动我们的贸易站，并乐于见到他们中有影响力的好心人陷入债务。因为我们观察到，当这些债务超过个人偿还能力时，他们就会愿意通过割让土地来抵偿。” 这说得够直白的了。
It's pretty straightforward. That's what he said.
非常直接。他就是这么说的。
And that's exactly what happened in the Minnesota territory. By 1851, the Dakota had come to rely on things they got from white traders-- guns, food, horses, kettles, and blankets, and traps. They were deep in debt, at least according to the traders themselves. And they were the ones keeping track. Here's Gwen.
而这正是明尼苏达领地所发生的事情。到1851年，达科他族人已不得不依赖从白人贸易商那里获得的东西——枪支、食物、马匹、水壶、毯子和捕兽夹。据贸易商自己说，他们背负了沉重的债务。而且是贸易商自己在记账。格温接着说。
And the government calls them in again to say, we'll help you with your debt, if you sell your land.
政府再次把他们召集起来说，如果你卖掉土地，我们就帮你解决债务。
Ben, could you sort of sum up what was the deal essentially?
本，你能总结一下这笔交易本质上是什么吗？
If you look at a map of Minnesota today, land-wise we're talking about basically, everything south of Interstate 94. So we're talking essentially about the lower half of Minnesota.
如果你看看今天的明尼苏达地图，从土地上讲，我们谈论的基本上是94号州际公路以南的所有地区。所以我们主要谈论的是明尼苏达的下半部分。
Plus some pieces of what would become Iowa and South Dakota. In two big treaties, one of them signed very near to the spot where the museum sits, the Dakota people traded away 35 million acres for about $3 million, which was a better price than some other tribes got.
加上后来成为爱荷华州和南达科他州的部分土地。通过两份大型条约，其中一份就在博物馆附近签署，达科他族人用3500万英亩的土地换取了约300万美元，这个价格比其他一些部落得到的还要好。
The treaties set aside a reservation for the Dakota-- 10 miles on either side of the Minnesota River stretching for 150 miles, a skinny strip in the middle of the vast territory the Dakota were giving up.
条约规定为达科他族人划出一块保留地——在明尼苏达河两侧各10英里，绵延150英里，这只是达科他族人放弃的广阔领地中间的一条狭长地带。
They didn't have much choice. They could see what was coming from the east-- a tidal wave of white settlers hungry for farm land, statehood, settlement. The white negotiators didn't have to say it out loud, but one of them did anyway. A guy named Luke Lea reminded the Dakota chiefs that the US government, quote, "could come with 100,000 men and drive you off to the Rocky Mountains."
他们没有太多选择。他们能看到从东部涌来的白色浪潮——渴望农田、州地位和定居的白人移民。白人谈判代表不必大声说出来，但其中一人还是说了。一个叫卢克·李（Luke Lea）的人提醒达科他酋长，美国政府，引用他的话，“可以带着10万大军把你赶到落基山脉去。”
A leading negotiator for the whites during these treaty deals was a man named Henry Sibley. Nobody was more important in the creation of the state of Minnesota. He'd later become its first governor.
这些条约交易期间白方的一位主要谈判代表是亨利·西布利（Henry Sibley）。没有人比他在明尼苏达州的建立过程中更重要。他后来成为了该州的第一任州长。
The treaty couldn't have happened without Henry Sibley.
如果没有亨利·西布利，这些条约就不可能达成。
To learn more about Sibley, I talked to this historian.
为了了解更多关于西布利的信息，我采访了这位历史学家。
I'm Mary Wingerd, and I wrote a book called North Country-- The Making of Minnesota.
我是玛丽·温格德（Mary Wingerd），我写了一本书叫《北方之国——明尼苏达的塑造》（North Country-- The Making of Minnesota）。
And it's pretty much the definitive history of Minnesota up to and including the US-Dakota War, isn't it?
这基本上是明尼苏达州直至美洲达科他战争为止最权威的历史书，对吧？
Well, I'm not going to say that. But yes, it is.
好吧，我不会这么说。但是的，它确实是。
Wingerd says Henry Sibley moved in from Detroit in the 1830s. He was just 23. The American Fur Company gave him a big job overseeing the southern half of what's now Minnesota.
温格德说，亨利·西布利在1830年代从底特律搬来。当时他才23岁。美国毛皮公司给了他一份大工作，监管现在明尼苏达州南部的一半领地。
Sibley had a child with a Dakota woman. He understood the Dakota language. He went before Congress criticizing treaties that, quote, "betrayed and deceived Indians."
西布利与一位达科他女性生有一个孩子。他懂达科他语。他曾向国会批评那些“背叛和欺骗印第安人”的条约。
And, as a young man, he just relished spending his time with the Dakota. And he would go out and hunt with them and really fostered good relations with them.
而且，年轻时的他非常喜欢和达科他族人待在一起。他会出去和他们打猎，确实与他们建立了良好的关系。
But the fur trade was a dying business. It was, economically, a dying business when he came here.
但是毛皮贸易当时是一个正在衰落的行业。在他来到这里时，这在经济上已经是一个夕阳产业。
By this time, the region had been over-hunted. Revenues were down. And everyone, from managers like Sibley to local traders on the frontier, down to the Dakota men who did the actual hunting, was in hock to the fur company, who would advance them money for all the supplies, traps, and guns.
到那时，该地区已经被过度捕猎。收入下降了。每个人，从西布利这样的经理人到边境的当地贸易商，再到真正从事捕猎的达科他男子，都抵押给了毛皮公司，公司预付给他们金钱以购买所有补给、陷阱和枪支。
Even though he may seem to be the big man in Minnesota, he is buried in debt. By 1849, he was really looking around for some other way to make a living. But he couldn't get out of the trade until he could pay his debts.
尽管他看起来可能是明尼苏达的大人物，但他负债累累。到1849年，他真的在寻找其他谋生方式。但他如果不偿还债务，就无法脱离毛皮贸易。
Because of his financial difficulties, he really played the Dakota people false.
因为他的经济困难，他真的背叛了达科他民族。
Sibley wrote to Pierre Chouteau, who held most of Sibley's debt. He boasted to him-- "The Indians are all prepared to make a treaty when we tell them to do so. And such a one as I may dictate. I think I may safely promise you that no treaty can be made without our claims being first secured."
西布利写信给皮埃尔·舒托（Pierre Chouteau），此人掌握着西布利大部分债务。他向他吹嘘：“当我们要印第安人签条约时，他们都准备好了。而且是我们可以指使的条约。我想我可以有把握地向你保证，没有我们的索赔首先得到满足，任何条约都不可能达成。”
Sibley and Chouteau said the Dakota owed them a lot of money. Those are the claims he's talking about. And they saw the treaties as a way to get paid. The way it happened was pretty ugly.
西布利和舒托称达科他族人欠他们很多钱。那就是他所说的索赔。他们把条约视为获得报酬的手段。事情的发展过程相当丑陋。
Take the treaty signed it Traverse des Sioux. The treaty was copied into the Dakota language for the chiefs to discuss. But their copy left out a key fact-- the government wasn't going to give the Dakota their payment in a lump sum, as the Dakota wanted and expected.
以在特拉弗斯德苏签署的条约为例。该条约被复制成了达科他语供酋长们讨论。但他们的副本漏掉了一个关键事实——政府不会像达科他族人想要和预期的那样一次性支付报酬。
Instead, the money would stay in the hands of the government to be doled out in much smaller, annual payments-- not just in gold, but also food and things like farming equipment.
相反，这笔钱会保留在政府手中，以更小额度的年度付款方式发放——不仅有黄金，还有食物和农具等物品。
The treaty did provide $305,000 in cash right away, most of it so the Dakota could quote-unquote "settle their affairs." After the signing of the treaty, Sibley's allies took the chiefs aside to sign a second document. The chiefs later said they thought it was just another copy of the treaty. But, in fact, they were agreeing to hand over most of that $305,000 to the traders, all but $60,000 to settle their debts.
条约确实立即提供了30万美元的现金，大部分是为了让达科他族人处理所谓的“财务纠纷”。条约签署后，西布利的盟友将酋长们拉到一边签署了第二份文件。酋长们后来表示，他们以为这只是条约的另一份副本。但实际上，他们同意将那30万美元中的大部分交给贸易商，除6万美元外，全部用于抵债。
So the traders got their money. Sibley himself walked away with $66,000-- more cash than the Dakota people got. Again, Mary Wingerd--
所以贸易商拿到了他们的钱。西布利本人拿到了6.6万美元——比达科他族人得到的现金还要多。再次引用玛丽·温格德的话——
That cleared him. That cleared his debts. That allowed him to get out of the trade. He has to know what he's doing. When he is faced with a moral dilemma of deal fairly with these people who have been my friends or take advantage of this opportunity to get out of this situation that I hate, he chooses his own self-interest.
这让他摆脱了债务。这让他得以脱离那个行业。他肯定知道自己在做什么。当他面临是公平对待这些曾经是自己朋友的人，还是利用这个机会摆脱自己厌恶的困境时，他选择了自己的个人利益。
Did you get a trail map or anything like that when you came in?
你进来的时候拿到导游地图了吗？
No, we didn't.
没有，我们没有。
We have some in there.
我们那里面有。
Gwen Westerman and I have driven west, out on the prairie, for the next bit of the story-- the build-up to the war. We've come to the Lower Sioux Agency. This was the federal government's outpost on Dakota land, near Redwood Falls, Minnesota. Sioux was the white man's name for the Dakota.
格温·韦斯特曼和我已经向西驱车来到大草原，去探寻故事的下一部分——战争的酝酿过程。我们来到了下苏族代理处（Lower Sioux Agency）。这是联邦政府在达科他土地上的前哨基地，靠近明尼苏达州的红杉瀑布（Redwood Falls）。苏族是白人对达科他人的称呼。
Oh, yeah, my name's Anthony Morris. I'm a ninth generation Lower Sioux Mdewakanton. My family's been here for at least 150 years. We actually have a picture of my seven-times great-grandfather in the museum here.
噢，是的，我叫安东尼·莫尔斯（Anthony Morris）。我是下苏族Mdewakanton人的第九代。我的家人在这里至少住了150年了。我们的博物馆里甚至还有我七代前曾祖父的照片。
Morse is just 26. He wears glasses and a wispy beard. He directs the historic site.
莫尔斯才26岁。他戴着眼镜，留着稀疏的胡子。他是这个历史遗址的负责人。
The government's two-story stone warehouse is still here, surrounded by open grassland. In 1862, it was stocked with government food shipments for distribution to the Dakota. These were paid out once a year under the terms of the treaty.
政府那座两层的石造仓库依然屹立在这里，周围是开阔的草原。1862年时，这里存放着准备分发给达科他族人的政府配给食品。根据条约，这些物资每年发放一次。
OK, so in 1862, where they're coming off a bad crop year in 1861, there's a lot of bad feelings that are brewing. They're really waiting for that annuity payment in June. They're waiting for their food and gold.
好吧，所以在1862年，他们刚经历了一个糟糕的收成，1861年的歉收导致了许多不满情绪。他们一直在等待6月份的那笔年金支付。他们等着食物和黄金。
The local area here would really look about like it would right now.
当地的情况看起来确实和现在差不多。
The annual federal shipment of gold and food promised in the 1851 treaty did not arrive on schedule in June. July passed and it didn't come. In the decade since the Dakota signed away their land, Minnesota had become a state. The white population exploded from 5,000 in 1850 to more than 170,000.
1851年条约承诺的年度联邦黄金和食品运输并未在6月份如期到达。7月过去了，物资还是没来。在达科他族人割让土地后的十年里，明尼苏达已经成为了一个州。白人人口从1850年的5000人激增到超过17万人。
Put another way, in 1850, Indians outnumbered whites in Minnesota 5 to 1. By 1860, it was the other way around.
换句话说，在1850年，明尼苏达的印第安人与白人的比例是5:1。到了1860年，情况完全反了过来。
And the Dakota were being squeezed into less and less space. Washington changed the terms of their treaties, took half the reservation back, and forced them to accept the new terms.
达科他族人被挤压在越来越小的空间里。华盛顿修改了他们的条约条款，收回了一半的保留地，并强迫他们接受新条款。
This didn't go down well. Minnesota's leaders thought that everything would be fine if the Dakota would just give up hunting, which required lots of land, and take up farming. Some did, cut their hair, raised crops.
这引发了强烈不满。明尼苏达的领导人认为，如果达科他族人能放弃需要大量土地的狩猎，转而从事耕种，一切都会好起来。有些人确实照做了，剪短头发，种植作物。
But, as you'd expect, a lot of Dakota wanted to live as they always had. Dakota man had always been hunters. Farming was seen as women's work. Hemmed in on their skinny reservation, lots of people couldn't feed themselves. By that August, things were desperate.
但是，正如你所料，很多达科他族人想继续过他们一直以来的生活。达科他男子向来是猎人。耕种被视为女人的工作。被困在狭窄的保留地上，许多人无法养活自己。到了那个8月，情况已经变得绝望了。
They were allowing their children to eat the unripened fruit off the trees, because they had to eat something. However, this unripened fruit would then make them sick. They would be even worse. And some people would end up dying because of these problems.
他们不得不让孩子吃树上未成熟的果子，因为他们必须吃点东西。然而，这些未成熟的水果反而让他们生病了。情况变得更糟。有些人甚至因为这些问题而丧命。
Meanwhile, the federal agent had food in the warehouse. But he refused to give it out to the Dakota until their full June payment arrived. Dakota men confronted a store-keeper named Andrew Myrick, asking him for help or credit.
与此同时，联邦代理商仓库里有食物。但他拒绝分发给达科他族人，直到他们全部的6月份付款到达。达科他男子面对一位名叫安德鲁·迈里克（Andrew Myrick）的店主，向他求助或要求赊账。
What do you expect us to feed our families?
你指望我们怎么养活家人？
And he said to let him eat grass. He considered them, basically, like livestock. They were considered animals to him.
他对他们说，让他们吃草去。他基本上把他们看作牲畜。对他来说，他们被视为动物。
There are some versions of that story that say Andrew Myrick said, let them eat grass or their own dung.
关于那个故事有一些版本说，安德鲁·迈里克说的是，让他们吃草或者吃他们自己的粪便。
In 200 years, there hadn't been much violence between Indians and whites in Minnesota. But in August of 1862, Dakota country was ready to blow up. Maybe the only question was, where would the spark come from?
在200年里，明尼苏达州的印第安人和白人之间几乎没有什么暴力冲突。但在1862年8月，达科他地区已处于爆发边缘。也许唯一的问题是，导火索从何而来？
That brings us back to the part of the story where Gwen and I began, in that farmyard in Acton, where the four young Dakota men killed the five settlers. There are other versions of the story. One comes from a Dakota, who spoke with the four young men, that don't include the Indians asking for liquor or the target-shooting contest.
这就回到了格温和我故事开始的地方，在Acton那个农场院子里，四名年轻的达科他男子杀害了五名定居者。这个故事还有其他版本。其中一个来自一位与这四名年轻人交谈过的达科他族人，其中并不包括印第安人索要酒精或进行射击比赛的情节。
The story ends the same way, though, with five settlers dead.
不过故事的结局是一样的，五名定居者死亡。
After the Acton massacre, the four boys rode back to the Lower Sioux Agency. That's where their village was located. They went back to their chief and relayed to him what they had done in Acton.
Acton大屠杀后，这四个男孩骑马回到了下苏族代理处。那里是他们村庄的所在地。他们回到酋长身边，转达了他们在Acton所做的事情。
This is Anthony Morse again.
这是安东尼·莫尔斯。
And so their chief called a meeting with more chiefs and they eventually called a council with all of the chiefs of Lower Sioux at one of Little Crow's houses, I believe.
于是他们的酋长召集了更多酋长开会，他们最终在小乌鸦的一间房子里召开了所有下苏族酋长的会议，我相信是这样的。
There they had their counsel on what they should do.
在那里他们商量该怎么做。
Little Crow was one of the leaders who signed the 1851 treaty that turned out so badly for the Dakota. When the chiefs and some riled up young men showed up at his house in the middle of the night, Little Crow said the white world would come down hard on all the Dakota, not just the four men who'd been at Acton.
小乌鸦是签署了1851年那份对达科他族人后果严重的条约的领导人之一。当酋长们和一些愤怒的年轻人半夜出现在他家时，小乌鸦说白人的世界会对所有达科他族人进行严厉的报复，而不仅仅是那四个在Acton的人。
A lot of the young warriors said the Dakota should attack first. Enough is enough, let's drive the whites out. But Little Crow wanted no part of that. He'd been to Washington, D.C. In those days the government liked to invite American Indian leaders to the capital to show them how powerful the new white man's country was.
许多年轻的勇士说达科他族人应该先发制人。忍无可忍，把白人赶出去。但小乌鸦不想参与其中。他曾去过华盛顿特区。在那段时期，政府喜欢邀请美洲印第安人领袖去首都，向他们展示这个新白人国家是多么强大。
Gwen Westerman, my traveling companion, is related to Little Crow. Like I said, her great-great-great-great-grandmother was the chief's sister. She says Little Crow-- whose name in Dakota is Ta Oyate Duta-- was one of many Dakota trying to adjust to the white culture and find a place in it.
我的旅伴格温·韦斯特曼与小乌鸦有亲戚关系。就像我说的，她的高祖母是这位酋长的姐妹。她说小乌鸦——他的达科他名字是Ta Oyate Duta——是许多试图适应白人文化并在其中寻找位置的达科他族人之一。
And, at this time, Ta Oyate Duta was living in a house and farming, trying--
而且，当时，Ta Oyate Duta正住在一所房子里耕种，试图——
And going to church.
并且去教堂。
--and going to church. Had cut his hair. And he was trying to establish a homestead here-- because this is Dakota homeland-- in the hopes-- I think-- of being able to stay here.
——并且去教堂。剪短了头发。他正试图在这里建立一个家园——因为这里是达科他的家园——希望——我认为——能够留在这里。
At first, when the young men started calling for war, what was Ta Oyate Duta's reaction, his take?
起初，当年轻人们开始呼吁战争时，Ta Oyate Duta的反应、他的态度是什么？
No. We can't fight. We have a responsibility to stay on this land and to live. And he knew that if the Dakota went to war against the United States, that all of that effort would be lost.
不。我们不能战斗。我们有责任留在这片土地上生活。他知道如果达科他族人对美国发动战争，那么所有的努力都将付诸东流。
Everyone argued about what to do. Little Crow made a speech that his son years later recited to a lawyer, who had it translated and written down. We asked an actor to read it.
每个人都争论该怎么做。小乌鸦发表了一篇演说，他的儿子多年后向一位律师背诵了这篇演说，律师将其翻译并记录了下来。我们请了一位演员来读这段话。
Braves, you're like little children. You know not what you are doing. See, the white men are like the locusts when they fly so thick that the whole sky is a snowstorm. You may kill 1, 2, 10-- yes, as many as the leaves in the forest yonder-- and their brothers will not miss them.
“勇士们，你们就像小孩子。你们不知道自己在做什么。看，白人就像蝗虫，他们飞过时厚重如雪暴。你们可能杀死1个、2个、10个——是的，就像森林里的落叶那么多——但他们的兄弟不会想念他们。”
Kill 1, 2, 10, and 10 times 10 will come to kill you. Yes, they fight among themselves away off.
“杀1个、2个、10个，会有10乘10个来杀你们。是的，他们在远方互相争斗。”
He's talking about the Civil War going on, to the southeast.
他指的是正在进行的南北战争，在东南方。
Do you hear the thunder of their big guns? No. It would take you two moons to run down to where they are fighting. And all the way your path would be among white soldiers, as thick as tamaracks in the swamps of the Ojibwes.
“你们听到他们大炮的轰鸣声了吗？没有。你们跑去他们战斗的地方需要两个月的时间。而这一路上，你们的道路将会布满白人士兵，像奥吉布韦（Ojibwe）沼泽里的落叶松一样密集。”
Yes, they fight among themselves. But if you strike at them, they will all turn on you and devour you, and your women, and little children.
“是的，他们确实在自相残杀。但如果你攻击他们，他们会全部转过来吞噬你们，还有你们的妇女和幼童。”
The young warriors called Little Crow a coward. His response--
年轻的勇士们叫小乌鸦懦夫。他的回应——
Ta Oyate Duta is not a coward. And he is not a fool. When did he run away from his enemies? When did he leave his braves behind him on the warpath and turn back to his tepee? You are fools.
“Ta Oyate Duta不是懦夫。他也不是傻瓜。他什么时候逃避过敌人？他什么时候在战争小径上把勇士留在身后，自己跑回帐篷？你们才是傻瓜。”
Braves, you are little children. You will die like the rabbits when the hungry wolves hunt them in the hard moon. Ta Oyate Duta is not a coward. He will die with you.
“勇士们，你们是小孩子。你们会像饥饿的狼在困难月份捕猎时的兔子一样死去。Ta Oyate Duta不是懦夫。他会和你们一起死。”
Most of Little Crow's band, along with men from other Dakota bands, decided to go to war. Historian Mary Wingerd calls the fighters a group of rash, young men. She says this is a crucial point that's often missed when the story of the conflict is told in Minnesota.
小乌鸦的大部分族人，连同其他达科他部落的男子，决定去打仗。历史学家玛丽·温格德称这些战士为一群鲁莽的年轻人。她说这是一个关键点，当明尼苏达州讲述这段冲突历史时，这一点经常被遗漏。
It is a complete myth that all the Dakota people went to war against the United States. So I have a little bit of trouble with calling it a war, actually. I know that that is the preferred terminology now. But they would get the idea that all the Dakota agreed that they were going to go to war the way the United States would go to war.
认为所有达科他族人都对美国发动战争是一个彻头彻尾的谎言。事实上，我甚至有点不习惯把它称为战争。我知道那是现在首选的术语。但人们会误以为所有达科他族人都在战争问题上达成了共识，就像美国参与战争那样。
But, in fact, of course, that wasn't the case. It was a faction that went on the offensive. And many people, particularly the Sissetons and Wahpetons, were opposed and wanted no part of it.
但事实上，当然并非如此。这是一个派系在发动进攻。许多人，特别是苏斯通（Sissetons）和瓦佩顿（Wahpetons）部落的人，持反对意见，不想参与其中。
Many men in those two bands did not fight. Over the coming weeks, the war and peace factions had angry debates and almost went to war with each other. Gwen Westerman tells me her own family was split. And she's not sure who did the right thing.
那两个部落中的许多男人没有参战。在接下来的几周里，主战派和主和派之间进行了愤怒的辩论，几乎爆发了内战。格温·韦斯特曼告诉我，她自己的家族也分裂了。她不确定谁做了正确的事。
One of my three-greats grandfathers in 1862 was with Sweet Corn's band, out on the prairie hunting buffalo. Another of my three-greats grandfathers was Mazamani, who was killed at the Battle at Wood Lake.
1862年，我的一位高祖父跟随“甜玉米”（Sweet Corn）部落在大草原上猎杀水牛。我的另一位高祖父是马扎马尼，他在伍德湖战役（Battle at Wood Lake）中牺牲。
Another of my three-greats grandfathers was Ishtakhaba, or Sleepy Eye, who didn't want to fight at all. The decisions that people made that allowed them to survive so that I could stand here today-- you can't second-guess those.
我的另一位高祖父是伊什塔卡巴（Ishtakhaba），或者叫“睡眼”（Sleepy Eye），他根本不想打仗。人们为了生存下去，让我今天能站在这里所做的决定——你不能事后质疑那些决定。
Coming up, a prairie home explosion. And, after it, a prairie home expulsion. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一场草原家园的爆炸。之后，是一场草原家园的驱逐。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目将继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today for the week after Thanksgiving-- "Little War on the Prairie," the history of settlers and Dakota Indians in Minnesota. John Biewen first put this story together for our show a few years ago, on the 150th anniversary of the so-called Sioux uprising and the war it led to.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。我们今天感恩节过后的节目——“草原上的小战争”，讲述明尼苏达州定居者和达科他印第安人的历史。约翰·比文几年前为我们的节目首次整理了这个故事，恰逢所谓的苏族起义及其引发的战争150周年。
During that anniversary year a few years back, probably more was said in Minnesota about these events than in the previous 100 years combined-- lots of newspaper articles and broadcasts and talks. Our guide to the story, John Biewen, grew up in Mankato. He now picks up the story where we left off before the break.
几年前的那个周年纪念年，明尼苏达州谈论这些事件的内容可能比过去100年的总和还要多——大量的报纸文章、广播和讲座。我们的故事向导约翰·比文在曼卡托长大。他现在接着我们在中断前的地方继续讲。
So the morning after Little Crow's speech, and after the murders at the Acton farm, August 18, 1862, several hundred Dakota warriors, led by Little Crow, started their assault at the federal outpost that sat on their land, the Lower Sioux Agency.
所以，在小乌鸦发表那篇演讲后的第二天早上，在Acton农场谋杀案发生后，1862年8月18日，由小乌鸦领导的数百名达科他勇士，在他们土地上的联邦前哨——下苏族代理处发动了袭击。
They took food from the stone warehouse, burned buildings, and killed about 20 men, one-fourth of the whites at the agency. The dead included the storekeeper who said that if Dakota families were hungry, they could eat grass. Again, Anthony Morse, who runs the agency's history center.
他们从石造仓库里拿走了食物，烧毁了建筑，杀死了大约20人，那是代理处四分之一的白人。死者中包括那位曾说如果达科他家庭饿了，可以去吃草的店主。再次引用负责代理处历史中心的安东尼·莫尔斯的话。
Andrew Myrick's body was found. He was more than likely fleeing from his home to the tall grass and the trees. However, he didn't quite make it. And his body was found filled with arrows and with grass stuffed in his mouth.
安东尼·迈里克的尸体被找到了。他很可能是从家里逃往高草丛和树林。然而，他没能跑掉。他的尸体被发现时浑身插满了箭，嘴里塞满了草。
Most of Minnesota's trained soldiers were off at the Civil War. When word of the attacks reached a nearby fort, some green, unprepared soldiers came to help. The Dakota ambushed them, killing almost everyone, and sending the rest fleeing for their lives.
明尼苏达州的大多数训练有素的士兵都在外地参加南北战争。当袭击的消息传到附近的堡垒时，一些毫无经验、准备不足的士兵赶来支援。达科他族人埋伏了他们，杀死了几乎所有人，剩下的落荒而逃。
From there, the Dakota men fanned out down the river valley, attacking the homes of settlers, most of them unarmed. Joseph Godfrey was a young, black man, who lived among the Dakota. He testified later that fall, telling how Dakota warriors he was with went house to house. This is an actor reading.
此后，达科他族男子散布到河谷，攻击定居者的家园，大多数定居者都没有武器。约瑟夫·戈弗雷（Joseph Godfrey）是一名生活在达科他族人中间的年轻黑人。他后来在秋天作证，讲述了他跟随的达科他勇士如何挨家挨户袭击。这是一位演员的朗读。
Dinner was on the table. And the Indians said, "After we kill, then we will have dinner." When we got near to a house, the Indians all got out and ran ahead of the wagons and two or three went to each house. And in that way, they killed all the people along the road.
“饭菜摆在桌上。印第安人说，‘杀完人之后，我们再吃饭。’当我们靠近一间屋子时，印第安人都从马车上跳下来冲到前面，每间屋子去了两三个人。就这样，他们杀死了路上的所有人。”
Some Dakota killed every settler they saw. Others killed only the men and took women and children captive. But many Dakota warriors spared and protected white people they knew. Even Chief Little Crow, the leader of the uprising, allowed a white woman named Sarah Wakefield, the wife of a local doctor, to take shelter in his house during the six weeks of the War.
一些达科他族人杀死了他们见到的每一个定居者。另一些人只杀男人，带走了妇女和儿童作为俘虏。但许多达科他勇士放过了并保护了他们认识的白人。就连起义领导人小乌鸦酋长，在战争的六周里，也允许一名名叫萨拉·韦克菲尔德（Sarah Wakefield）的白人女性（当地医生的妻子）在他家中避难。
One Dakota woman who opposed the fighting, named Snana, took in a 14-year-old German girl who had been captured by a warrior. Snana traded him a pony for the girl. Snana wrote down her story in 1901. Turns out, her daughter had died recently, and she was heartbroken.
一位反对战斗的达科他女性斯纳纳（Snana），收留了一名被勇士俘虏的14岁德国女孩。斯纳纳用一匹小马从那个人手中换回了这个女孩。斯纳纳在1901年记下了她的故事。原来，她的女儿最近去世了，她心碎不已。
The reason why I wished to keep this girl was to have her in place of the one I lost. So I loved her and pitied her. And she was dear to me, just the same as my own daughter. During the outbreak, when some of the Indians got killed, they began to kill some of the captives. At such times I always hid my dear captive white girl. I thought to myself that if they would kill my girl, they must kill me first.
“我希望留下这个女孩的原因是让她代替我失去的那个。所以我爱她，可怜她。她对我来说很珍贵，就像我自己的女儿一样。起义期间，当一些印第安人被杀时，他们开始杀害一些俘虏。在那种时候，我总是把我也亲爱的白人女孩藏起来。我对自己说，如果他们要杀我的女孩，必须先杀了我。”
The historian Mary Wingerd is a fifth-generation Minnesotan. She says for 100 years or more, Minnesotans who heard the story at all heard a one-sided tale of savage Indians attacking innocent whites out of the blue.
历史学家玛丽·温格德是第五代明尼苏达人。她说，一百多年来，偶尔听说这个故事的明尼苏达人听到的都是单方面的叙述：残暴的印第安人无缘无故地袭击无辜的白人。
Now most historians like herself blame the war mainly on white double-dealing and bullying.
现在，大多数像她这样的历史学家将战争的主要原因归咎于白人的双重交易和霸凌行为。
But I also think it's a mistake to try to pretend that there was no wrongs committed by the men who rode against the settlers. A minimum 400 innocent civilians were murdered, most of them who didn't even have weapons-- women and children.
但我同时也认为，试图假装这些骑马攻击定居者的人没有犯下任何错误是错误的。至少有400名无辜的平民被谋杀，其中大多数甚至没有武器——包括妇女和儿童。
The Dakota people were victims, big time. But most of the people who died were victims as well. The people who would have been worthy opponents in a war were untouchable.
达科他族人确实是极大的受害者。但大多数死者也是受害者。那些本应在战争中成为势均力敌对手的人（即那些政策制定者）却毫发无损。
Meaning the men in St. Paul and Washington, D.C. who wrote, then violated, the treaties. The fighting lasted 36 days. Dakota warriors attacked New Ulm twice and looted and burned a couple other towns.
指的是在圣保罗和华盛顿特区制定并随后违反条约的人。战斗持续了36天。达科他勇士两次袭击了新乌尔姆（New Ulm），并洗劫和烧毁了其他几个城镇。
White settlers turned into panicked refugees, fleeing across the prairie. And the man appointed to lead a force to defeat the Dakota? Henry Sibley. You remember Sibley, the fur trader who helped orchestrate the treaties of 1851.
白人定居者变成了惊慌失措的难民，逃离草原。而那位被任命去领导军队击败达科他族人的人呢？亨利·西布利。你还记得西布利吗，那个策划了1851年条约的毛皮贸易商。
Well, Sibley has no military experience whatsoever. But he does know the Dakota well. And he knows what great warriors they are. And he has the most hodgepodge troops ever. And he doesn't have enough weaponry.
嗯，西布利完全没有任何军事经验。但他非常了解达科他族人。他知道他们是多么伟大的勇士。他手下的军队拼凑得乱七八糟。而且他缺乏足够的武器装备。
And so he's moving very slowly towards southwestern Minnesota. And, of course, every step of the way, the newspapers are excoriating him.
所以他正极其缓慢地向明尼苏达西南部推进。当然，一路上报纸都在严厉抨击他。
They called him a snail and a coward and the state undertaker, because Sibley's militia showed a knack for arriving after battles were over to help bury the dead.
他们叫他“蜗牛”、“懦夫”和“州验尸官”，因为西布利的民兵总有一种在战斗结束后才赶到现场帮忙掩埋尸体的“天赋”。
They accuse him of not really wanting to go after the Dakota, because he's really too close to them and all his sympathies are with them. So Sibley, with his very thin skin, is beside himself.
他们指责他其实根本不想追击达科他族人，因为他和他们走得太近，所有的同情心都在他们那边。所以西布利，脸皮很薄，简直要气疯了。
And I think that that helps explain the really extraordinarily severe attitude he had toward all the Dakota people following the conflict I really think it was because he felt he was personally betrayed.
我认为这有助于解释为什么他在冲突后对所有达科他族人采取了那种极其严厉的态度，我真的认为是因为他觉得自己在个人层面上被背叛了。
Sibley had seen himself as a friend to the Dakota. He believed they could take up farming and co-exist with white people in Minnesota. But now even some Dakota he knew-- men who had started to assimilate-- were murdering settlers.
西布利曾视自己为达科他族人的朋友。他相信他们可以改种庄稼，并在明尼苏达与白人和睦相处。但现在，即使是他认识的一些达科他族人——那些开始同化的人——也在谋杀定居者。
In his letters, Sibley was bitter. Quote, "A great public crime has been committed, not by wild Indians who did not know better, but by men who have had advantages, intercourse with white men."
在他的信件中，西布利非常痛苦。引用他的话，“一个巨大的公共罪行已经发生，不是由不明事理的野蛮印第安人犯下的，而是由那些拥有优势、与白人有过交往的人犯下的。”
In another he wrote, "Tame the Indian. Cultivate him. Strive to Christianize him as you will. And the sight of blood will, in an instant, call out the savage, wolfish, devilish instincts in his race."
在另一封信中他写道：“驯化印第安人。教化他。无论你如何努力使他基督化。鲜血的刺激会瞬间唤醒他们种族中野蛮、狼性、恶魔般的本能。”
Years before all this, Sibley had warned that if the federal government kept cheating Indians in treaties, the result would be war. Now that very thing was happening in his own state. And he himself had helped convinced the Indians to sign those crooked treaties. But there was no indication Sibley took any blame, says Wingerd.
在这一切发生的前几年，西布利曾警告说，如果联邦政府在条约中继续欺骗印第安人，后果将是战争。现在，同样的事情正在他自己的州发生。而他自己曾帮助说服印第安人签署那些狡诈的条约。但没有迹象表明西布利承担了任何责任，温格德说。
To me, it's perfectly plausible that he could deny to himself that all the things he did really hurt them. And if only they would accept the route to civilization and become farmers, they would be fine. If only they would do it this way, they would be OK.
对我来说，他可以否认他所做的一切确实伤害了他们，这是完全合理的。只要他们愿意接受文明之路成为农民，他们就会没事的。如果他们只是按这种方式做，他们就会没事的。
Altogether in the six-week war, somewhere between 400 and 1,000 white people died, most of them settlers. Not as many Dakota died-- maybe 50 to 100 in the war itself. But payback was still to come.
在六周的战争中，总共约有400到1000名白人死亡，其中大多数是定居者。死亡的达科他族人没那么多——战争中约有50到100人。但报复还在后头。
Our course, then, is plain-- the Sioux Indians of Minnesota must be exterminated or driven forever beyond the borders of the state.
“那么，我们的方针很明确——明尼苏达州的苏族印第安人必须被灭绝，或者永远被驱逐出本州边界之外。”
This is what Minnesota governor Alexander Ramsey said to a special session of the state legislature, during the war in September of 1862.
这是明尼苏达州州长亚历山大·拉姆齐（Alexander Ramsey）在1862年9月战争期间对州议会特别会议所说的话。
If any shall escape extinction, the wretched remnant must be driven beyond our borders and our frontier garrisoned with a force sufficient to forever prevent their return.
“如果有谁逃脱了灭绝，这些悲惨的残余必须被驱逐到我们的边界之外，并派遣足以防止他们返回的武装部队驻守我们的边境。”
It's not surprising that white Minnesotans were enraged by the attacks. But things got extreme. A newspaper columnist named Jane Grey Swisshelm called for a bounty for Sioux scalps. And months later, the state started offering $75 each, and eventually $200.
白人明尼苏达人对袭击感到愤怒并不奇怪。但事情变得极端了。一位名叫简·格雷·斯威瑟姆（Jane Grey Swisshelm）的专栏作家呼吁悬赏苏族人的头皮。几个月后，该州开始提供每张头皮75美元的奖金，后来涨到了200美元。
Chief Little Crow and a couple hundred of the most militant warriors had fled west, out of Minnesota. The rest of the Dakota people gathered voluntarily at a makeshift camp on the prairie to wait for Colonel Henry Sibley.
小乌鸦酋长和两百名最激进的勇士已经向西逃出了明尼苏达州。其余的达科他族人自愿聚集在大草原的一个临时营地，等待亨利·西布利上校。
Most were women, children, and old men who had not participated in the killing. Here's Gwen again.
大多数是没参加过杀戮的妇女、儿童和老人。再次引用格温的话。
There are letters back and forth between Henry Sibley and the leaders on the Dakota side where he specifically said, come out under a flag of truce. You'll be protected. I'll protect you. You have my word.
亨利·西布利和达科他一方的领导人之间有来往信件，他明确表示，在休战旗帜下出来。你们会受到保护。我会保护你们。你们有我的诺言。
And like some other promises that had been made along the way--
就像这一路走来所做的其他承诺一样——
That one was not honored either.
那个承诺也没有得到兑现。
The Dakota trusted Sibley's promise that only those who had murdered settlers would be punished. But the 1,700 Dakota civilians were marched 150 miles down the Minnesota River, a mini Trail of Tears. In towns along the way, white people attacked them with rocks, clubs, and knives.
达科他族人相信西布利的承诺，即只有杀害定居者的凶手才会受到惩罚。但这1700名达科他平民被强迫沿明尼苏达河行进了150英里，经历了一场小型的“血泪之路”。沿途的城镇里，白人用石头、棍棒和刀子攻击他们。
A half-Dakota man named Samuel Brown was long for the march, working for the government. He wrote in his diary that in the town of Henderson, a white woman grabbed a baby from a Dakota woman's arms and threw it at the ground, killing the baby.
一个名叫塞缪尔·布朗（Samuel Brown）的半血缘达科他男子在行军途中为政府工作。他在日记中写道，在亨德森镇，一个白人妇女从一个达科他妇女怀里抢走婴儿并扔在地上，摔死了婴儿。
The Dakota walked for a week, says historian Mary Wingerd, until they reached their destination near St. Paul.
历史学家玛丽·温格德说，达科他族人走了一周，直到他们到达圣保罗附近的目的地。
What was essentially a concentration camp at Fort Snelling, where they were kept until the spring of 1863. And then they were transported to a reservation, Crow Creek, South Dakota. It was in Dakota Territory, which was the next best thing to hell. And the death toll was just shocking.
“那本质上是斯内林堡（Fort Snelling）的一个集中营，他们被关在那里直到1863年春天。然后他们被转移到一个保留地——南达科他州的克劳克里克（Crow Creek）。那是在达科他领地，仅次于地狱的地方。死亡人数简直令人震惊。”
Hundreds of Dakota, mostly children and old people, died of disease over the winter in Fort Snelling. About 100 more died on boats that took them down the Mississippi and up the Missouri to Dakota Territory.
数百名达科他族人，主要是儿童和老人，在斯内林堡的那个冬天死于疾病。还有大约100人死在将他们运往密西西比河下流，再转向密苏里河进入达科他领地的船上。
Still more hundreds died at the South Dakota reservation. As Wingerd puts it, this was the thanks most of the Dakota got for opposing the war.
更多的人死在南达科他州的保留地。正如温格德所言，这就是大多数达科他族人因反对战争而得到的报答。
They lost everything. They lost their lands. They lost all their annuities that were owed them from the treaties. These are people who are guilty of nothing.
他们失去了一切。他们失去了土地。他们失去了条约所欠他们的所有年金。这些人什么罪都没有犯。
[WIND BLOWING]
[风声]
OK, I'm going to get some sound of the wind here.
好吧，我要录点风的声音。
Gwen and I are back in Mankato, my hometown, where she now teaches at the State University. It's windy, but otherwise a nice day in October. We're in an old park, a favorite place of mine-- big trees with bright yellow leaves, picnic tables.
格温和我回到了我的家乡曼卡托，她现在在州立大学任教。风很大，但除此之外，这是一个美好的十月日子。我们在我最喜欢的一个老公园里——巨大的树木，金黄色的叶子，还有野餐桌。
Alongside the park, the Blue Earth River, that I canoed on as a kid, flows into the Minnesota River.
公园旁，我小时候划过独木舟的蓝地河（Blue Earth River）汇入明尼苏达河。
And it was right down here, on this sandy river bank that my family used to build a fire and roast hot dogs and marshmallows and sit out here at night and have just a lovely time on a fall night like this.
就在这儿，在这片我小时候家人常来生火、烤热狗和棉花糖、晚上坐在这里度过美好秋夜的沙质河岸上。
We should have brought hot dogs.
我们应该带热狗来的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This is where the Dakota men ended up-- the ones who turned themselves in after Henry Sibley promised to treat them fairly. Sibley set up a kangaroo court out on the prairie and tried 400 of them in a few weeks.
这就是达科他男子最后抵达的地方——那些在亨利·西布利承诺公平对待他们后自首的人。西布利在大草原上建立了一个袋鼠法庭（非正规法庭），在几周内审判了其中的400人。
He didn't let the Dakota have lawyers or witnesses. Some trials lasted five minutes. He named a panel of five US soldiers who had just been fighting against the Dakota to hand out verdicts and death sentences.
他不允许达科他族人请律师或证人。有些审判只持续了五分钟。他指定了一个由五名刚刚与达科他族人战斗过的美国士兵组成的小组来作出判决和死刑。
Sibley's court condemned 303 Dakota men. A report was sent to President Lincoln on the plan to hang all of them. The president, fresh off the bloodiest day in American history at Antietam, was stunned by the long list. He ordered the Minnesotans to hold off on the hangings until his office could review the trial transcripts. So they waited right here. They called it Camp Lincoln.
西布利的法庭判处了303名达科他男子死刑。一份关于悬挂所有这些人的计划的报告被发给了林肯总统。总统，刚经历过美国历史上最血腥的安提塔姆战役（Antietam），被那份冗长的名单惊呆了。他命令明尼苏达人暂停绞刑，直到他的办公室能审查完审判记录。所以他们就等在这里。他们把它称为“林肯营地”（Camp Lincoln）。
You can imagine teepees and fires and tents, soldiers.
你可以想象那场景：帐篷、火堆、士兵。
She points up at a high bluff across the river. Vengeful settlers would perch up there and shoot into the camp at the Dakota.
她指向河对岸的一座高崖。充满复仇心理的定居者会蹲在那里，向达科他人的营地开火。
There were people who died here because of that. So a lot of people don't know that that's what was here. Or they think of Camp Lincoln, was near here, we don't know where. Or they don't think about it at all.
有人因为那个原因死在这里。所以很多人不知道这里曾经是什么。或者他们认为林肯营地就在附近，但不知道在哪儿。或者他们根本就没想过。
I can tell you that growing up, I had no idea. Never heard of Camp Lincoln.
我可以告诉你，我在那儿长大时，根本不知道这些。从未听说过林肯营地。
For me and most people in Mankato, this was just Sibley Park. That's right-- Sibley Park, named after the man who led the charge to shove the Dakota off their homeland to make way for-- well, people like me.
对我及曼卡托的大多数人来说，这只是西布利公园（Sibley Park）。没错——西布利公园，以那个领导将达科他族人赶出家园，为我们这样的人让路的人命名。
There's a Henry Sibley High School in the Twin Cities. Sibley County is just up the road from Mankato. Living in the South for more than a decade, I still shake my head a little at the highways and schools named after the great defenders of slavery-- Jeff Davis, Nathan Bedford Forrest.
双子城有一所亨利·西布利高中。西布利县离曼卡托也不远。在南方生活了十多年后，看到那些以伟大的奴隶制捍卫者——杰夫·戴维斯、内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特——命名的高速公路和学校，我仍然会摇头。
Now here I am, well into middle age, and it's just now sinking in-- in my hometown, Sibley Park.
现在我已步入中年，才刚刚意识到这一点——在我的家乡，西布利公园。
In Washington, in the fall of 1862, President Lincoln was getting heated messages from the governor and others in Minnesota. They said he'd better allow the hanging of the 303 Dakota men or else furious white people might go vigilante.
在华盛顿，1862年的秋天，林肯总统收到来自明尼苏达州州长和其他人的激烈信件。他们说他最好批准悬挂那303名达科他男子，否则愤怒的白人可能会采取私刑。
Lynch mobs formed in Mankato and other towns and had to be quelled by soldiers. Newspapers told horrifying stories that Dakota warriors had mutilated babies and raped countless settler women, though very few of those claims were ever backed up. President Lincoln wired back to Minnesota.
曼卡托和其他城镇形成了私刑暴徒，不得不被士兵镇压。报纸刊登了骇人听闻的故事，称达科他勇士残害婴儿并强奸了无数定居者女性，尽管这些指控几乎没有得到任何证实。林肯总统给明尼苏达州发了电报。
And so Lincoln says, OK, so the ones who ought to be put to death are the ones who raped women. So go through these cases and identify the ones who are guilty of violating women. And, as it turns out, they can only find two cases of rape.
于是林肯说，好吧，那些应该被处死的人是那些强奸妇女的人。所以检查这些案件，找出那些犯有强奸妇女罪的人。结果，他们只找到了两起强奸案件。
And hanging two Indians would not satisfy the people of Minnesota, the president was told. So Lincoln had his people review the trial transcripts for evidence that the men had attacked settlers, and not just shown up at battles.
总统被告知，绞死两名印第安人无法满足明尼苏达人民的愿望。于是林肯让人审查了审判记录，寻找这些人参与袭击定居者而不仅仅是出现在战场上的证据。
In the end, Lincoln himself wrote out a list of 39 Dakota names-- later trimmed to 38. The day after Christmas, those men were marched on to a big platform in Mankato's town square. Hoods were pulled over their heads.
最终，林肯亲自写下了39个达科他人的名字——后来削减为38个。圣诞节过后的第二天，这些人被押上曼卡托市政广场的一个大平台。他们的头上被套上头罩。
4,000 people had come from miles around to watch. The men held each other's hands and sang prayers till the moment the floor under them dropped away. They fell. And the chanting stopped.
4000人从几英里外赶来观看。男人们手拉着手，唱着祈祷文，直到他们脚下的地板掉落的那一刻。他们坠落。吟唱声停止了。
Little Crow was shot six months after the hangings. And his scalp, skull, and wrist bones were displayed at the Minnesota Historical Society for decades. Mary Wingerd says, for a short time after the war, Minnesotans were triumphant at having beaten back the savage Indians. They relished the story.
小乌鸦在绞刑六个月后被枪杀。他的头皮、头骨和手腕骨在明尼苏达州历史协会展出了几十年。玛丽·温格德说，战争后的一小段时间里，明尼苏达人为击退了野蛮的印第安人而感到胜利。他们沉浸在这个故事中。
So there's lots of dime novels coming out and panoramas that are created. And the whole country is fascinated and mesmerized by this horrible thing that happened.
于是出现了大量通俗小说和全景图画。整个国家都被这段发生的可怕事件所吸引和迷住。
Well, it doesn't take people in Minnesota very long to figure out, afterwards, this is really, really bad PR. This is not good. And how will we encourage people to come to Minnesota if they think they're going to be scalped the minute they step out of their cabin.
好吧，明尼苏达人没过多久就意识到，这是非常、非常糟糕的公关。这不妙。如果人们认为他们一踏出小屋就会被剥头皮，我们该如何鼓励人们来明尼苏达呢。
So, she says, Minnesotans clammed up about the nastiness of 1862. Instead, they embraced a gauzy, fantastical version of the state's Indian heritage.
所以，她说，明尼苏达人对1862年的丑事闭口不谈。相反，他们拥抱了一个关于该州印第安遗产的虚幻、奇妙的版本。
The message that boosters wanted to portray of Minnesota is that Minnesota was this beautiful, natural place and that we have these lovely legends of long-gone, noble savages.
宣传者想要描绘的明尼苏达形象是：明尼苏达是一个美丽、自然的地方，我们拥有这些关于远古、高尚野蛮人的美好传说。
So does that help explain how I could grow up in Minnesota 100 years later, in Mankato even, and not hear anything about all this history?
那么，这是否有助于解释我怎么能在100年后在明尼苏达长大，甚至是在曼卡托长大，却对所有这些历史一无所知？
Well, yes. I think that explains a good part of it. I think people of your generation and my generation never really felt that Indians were really part of the past of this place-- that they were stories like Paul Bunyan and Babe the Blue Ox.
嗯，是的。我认为这解释了一大部分原因。我认为你那一代人和我这一代人从来没觉得印第安人真正是这个地方过去的一部分——他们就像保罗·班扬（Paul Bunyan）和宝贝蓝牛（Babe the Blue Ox）一样的故事角色。
Today, visitors to Minneapolis can drive down Hiawatha Boulevard and visit Minnehaha Falls, references to Longfellow's romanticized poem, "Song of Hiawatha." Countless Minnesota businesses use native names and imagery-- Land O'Lakes butter, with its Indian maiden on the box. There's a Little Crow country club. For years, the logo of the gas company-- Minnegasco-- was an Indian girl with a blue flame as the feather in her headdress.
今天，明尼阿波利斯的游客可以开车沿海华沙大道（Hiawatha Boulevard）行驶，参观明尼哈哈瀑布（Minnehaha Falls），这些都参考了朗费罗（Longfellow）浪漫化的诗歌《海华沙之歌》。无数明尼苏达企业使用土著名称和意象——Land O'Lakes黄油，包装盒上有印第安少女。有个小乌鸦乡村俱乐部。多年来，天然气公司Minnegasco的标志是一个印第安女孩，头上插着一根蓝色的羽毛。
There are probably other reasons white Minnesotans don't remember the US-Dakota War. I suspect a big one is we won. Mary Wingerd and Gwen Westerman both say they routinely meet students who've grown up in the area and arrive at college with no knowledge of the US-Dakota War-- never heard of it.
白人明尼苏达人不记得美洲达科他战争可能还有其他原因。我怀疑其中一个重要的原因是：我们赢了。玛丽·温格德和格温·韦斯特曼都表示，她们经常遇到在当地长大的学生，他们上了大学却对美洲达科他战争一无所知——从没听说过。
Girls, let's pick up the balls, please. Go grab a drink of water.
女孩们，把球捡起来，拜托。去喝口水吧。
I stopped by my old high school, Mankato West, to see what kids know now.
我去了我的母校曼卡托西高中（Mankato West），看看孩子们现在了解什么。
I need five upperclassmen over here, quick.
我需要五个高年级学生过来，快。
The girls' tennis coach rounded up a few seniors for an extremely unscientific survey.
女子网球队教练找来几个高年级学生做了一次极其不科学的调查。
So what do you know about-- it's usually called, these days, the Dakota War, the US-Dakota War?
那么，你们对现在通常称为达科他战争、美洲达科他战争了解多少？
I know it happened at the same time as the Civil War, which is why a lot of people don't know about it. But it was one of the biggest fights between Americans and the Native Americans.
我知道它发生在南北战争时期，这就是为什么很多人不知道它的原因。但它是美国人和美洲原住民之间最大的战斗之一。
And we just talk about it like every year, basically. It always comes up and they always say it's the biggest mass hanging. It's pretty sad that it had to happen here and that we're known for it.
我们基本上每年都在谈论它。它总是被提起，而且他们总说是最大规模的集体绞刑。这里发生过这种事，而且我们因它而闻名，这挺悲哀的。
I did talk to other young people in southern Minnesota who knew nothing of the Dakota War. But things have changed since I was a kid. Every sixth grader in Minnesota is now supposed to learn about the war, at least a little.
我也和曼卡托南部的其他年轻人谈过，他们对达科他战争一无所知。但情况和我小时候相比已经变了。现在明尼苏达的每个六年级学生都应该了解这场战争，至少了解一点。
It's a week-long unit in the state's Minnesota History textbook. In Mankato they do more. I met a teacher who spends twice as much time because of the local connection. Every third grader goes to a Dakota powwow in September. But the quality of the teaching varies.
这是该州《明尼苏达历史》教科书中的一周学习单元。在曼卡托，他们做得更多。我见过一位老师，因为当地的联系，她花了双倍的时间来讲。每个三年级学生九月份都会去参加达科他人的庆典（powwow）。但教学质量参差不齐。
So show me you're prepared.
给我展示一下你们准备好了。
Monroe Elementary is just across the Minnesota River from the hanging site. Patricia Hammann is prepping her third grade class for the powwow. I asked her how she presents the war of 1862, standing with her in front of her students.
门罗小学（Monroe Elementary）就在绞刑遗址的明尼苏达河对岸。帕特里夏·哈曼（Patricia Hammann）正在为她的三年级班级准备参加庆典。我站在学生们面前问她如何介绍1862年的战争。
We just talked about, like a conflict is a disagreement. And we talked how the Dakota Indians didn't know how to solve their conflicts. And the only way they knew how to solve their disagreements was to fight, which we know, we don't fight when we solve conflicts. We use our words.
我们只是谈论过，冲突就是意见不合。我们谈论了达科他印第安人不知道如何解决他们的冲突。他们知道解决分歧的唯一方法就是战斗，而我们知道，解决冲突时我们不打架。我们要用言语沟通。
But that was their only way that they knew how to solve a conflict. They fought. And so then the white settlers needed to fight back to protect themselves. And then we talked about, people were killed. And then we talked about how the Dakota Indians were--
但这只是他们所知道的解决冲突的唯一方法。他们打了仗。然后白人定居者需要回击来保护自己。然后我们讨论了人们被杀的事。然后我们谈论了达科他印第安人是——
My guess is that no Dakota children were in the room to take offense. In 1863, Congress passed a law confiscating all the Dakota's land in Minnesota. President Lincoln signed it, effectively banishing the Dakota from the state.
我的猜测是，房间里没有达科他孩子会感到被冒犯。1863年，国会通过了一项没收明尼苏达州所有达科他土地的法律。林肯总统签署了它，有效地将达科他族人驱逐出该州。
About 25 years later, Congress allowed some Dakota, who were considered "friendly," to return and establish small settlements in the state. So today four Dakota communities are dotted across southern Minnesota.
大约25年后，国会允许一些被认为是“友好的”达科他族人返回并在该州建立小定居点。所以今天有四个达科他社区散布在明尼苏达南部。
But for Gwen and all the other Dakota who grew up elsewhere, the federal expulsion from Minnesota-- their homeland-- is still on the books.
但对于格温和所有在其他地方长大的达科他族人来说，联邦政府将他们从明尼苏达——他们的家园——驱逐出去，依然记录在案。
How are things going to go is no walkers go past here.
事情会怎么样，现在没有行人在过去。
This past August, to mark the 150th anniversary of the start of the US-Dakota War, a symbolic walk home, organized by several Dakota bands and reservations. Gwen and I went.
去年8月，为了纪念美洲达科他战争开始150周年，几个达科他部落和保留地组织了一次象征性的回家之旅。格温和我去了。
Well, we're standing here today in the midst of cornfields on all sides of this intersection, under an incredibly beautiful blue sky, at the state line between South Dakota and Minnesota, as we make that walk back into Minnesota 150 years after we were forced to leave.
“嗯，今天我们站在这个路口的玉米地中间，在难以置信美丽的蓝天下，在南达科他州和明尼苏达州的州界上，纪念我们在被迫离开150年后再次走回明尼苏达。”
The highway patrol has closed off a section of road, where South Dakota's Highway 34 meets Minnesota Highway 30.
高速公路巡警关闭了南达科他34号公路与明尼苏达30号公路交汇处的一段道路。
[HORSE NOISE]
[马鸣声]
There are a dozen Dakota on horseback and many more on foot. A handful of white Minnesotans greet them with signs saying "Welcome home."
有十几个骑马的达科他族人，还有许多步行的人。少数白人明尼苏达人带着写有“欢迎回家”的标语迎接他们。
Thank you! Thank you for coming back! Thank you.
谢谢！谢谢你们回来！谢谢。
About 40 yards shy of the state line--
距离州界还有约40码——
That's about as far as I can let you guys go.
我就能让你们走到这儿了。
--organizers ask reporters to turn off our equipment if we want to witness the ceremony up close.
——组织者要求记者关掉设备，如果我们想近距离见证仪式的话。
Maybe 100 people form a big circle around eight older Dakota women. They pass eagle feathers across the line into Minnesota and sweep sage smoke on themselves. There are prayers and tears.
大约100个人围成一个大圆圈，八位年长的达科他女性站在中间。她们将老鹰羽毛从界线传向明尼苏达一侧，并用鼠尾草的烟雾熏自己。有祈祷和泪水。
[BACKGROUND CHATTER]
[背景杂谈]
I have a much different response than I had anticipated. And I think it started yesterday when they told us that Governor Dayton had made today-- declared today-- a day of remembrance and reconciliation. And that he repudiated Governor Ramsey's words about extermination and exile.
我的反应比预想的要强烈得多。我认为昨天开始就已经这样了，当时他们告诉我们戴顿州长已经宣布今天——被定为纪念与和解日。他否认了拉姆齐州长关于灭绝和流亡的话。
Minnesota's governor, Mark Dayton, said he was appalled by Governor Ramsay's words in 1862. Dayton stated flatly that the US used deception and force to take Indian lands and broke its promises.
明尼苏达州州长马克·戴顿（Mark Dayton）表示，他对拉姆齐州长1862年的言论感到震惊。戴顿断然指出，美国利用欺骗和武力夺取了印第安人的土地，并违背了诺言。
And when I heard that-- when I heard that, it was overwhelming in a way that I hadn't anticipated. Because I thought it would be, yes! It's about time! Or I don't know.
当我听到这个的时候——当我听到那个时候，那种压倒性的感觉是我始料未及的。因为我想我会说，太好了！终于等到这一天了！或者我不知道。
But that's not the way it felt. It was relief. It was an overwhelming feeling. And I wanted to cry. But I was in a restaurant. And I was glad I had sunglasses on. So I held it together then.
但感觉并不像那样。那是解脱。那是一种压倒性的感觉。我想哭。但我当时在餐厅里。我很高兴我戴着太阳镜。所以当时我强忍住了。
But about two weeks ago, I was giving a presentation at the Minnesota Historical Society. And during the question session, somebody said, well, what do you want? Do you want reparations?
但大约两周前，我在明尼苏达州历史协会做演讲。在问答环节，有人问，好吧，你想要什么？你想要赔偿吗？
And the person who asked the question was almost accusatory-- well, what do you want? What more do you want? And I said, what we want is acknowledgment that this happened. And so, to hear what the governor did, this is a turning point.
提出这个问题的人几乎带有指责的语气——好吧，你想要什么？你还想要什么？我说，我们想要的是对这件事的承认。所以，听到州长所做的，这是一个转折点。
We want to be acknowledged. And here it is.
我们想要被承认。而这就是结果。
The history of every place is more complicated than the people who live there like to believe. And every moment in history is just as complex as the moment we're living in right now.
每个地方的历史都比居住在这里的人们愿意相信的要复杂。历史上的每一刻都像我们现在所处的时刻一样复杂。
I have a friend, Tim Tyson, a historian I work with at Duke, who points out that in his home state of North Carolina, up to one third of the white people were pro-Union during the Civil War. And a year into the war-- 1862-- the state elected a governor who'd opposed both slavery and secession.
我有一个朋友，蒂姆·泰森（Tim Tyson），是我在杜克大学合作的一位历史学家，他指出在他家乡北卡罗来纳州，南北战争期间多达三分之一的白人支持北方联邦。在战争进行到一年时——1862年——该州选举出一位既反对奴隶制又反对分裂的州长。
And yet there's no memory that white people opposed the Civil War. There's no memory that General Pickett, of Pickett's Charge, came to Kinston, North Carolina in 1864. And the first thing he did was he hanged 22 local white boys on the courthouse lawn because they were loyal to the United States government.
然而，人们并没有白人反对南北战争的记忆。没有皮克特冲锋（Pickett's Charge）的皮克特将军在1864年来到北卡罗来纳州金斯顿（Kinston）的记忆。他做的第一件事就是吊死了22名当地白人男孩，因为他们忠于美国政府。
And you go down to Kinston now and you go out to King's Barbecue and you look down the row of cars, at all those trucks and all those Confederate-flag bumper stickers. And I just want to say, you don't know who you are. They hanged your great-granddaddy. And you got their flag on your bumper. That's kind of interesting.
你现在去金斯顿，去金氏烧烤店（King's Barbecue），看看那一排排汽车，看看那些卡车和邦联旗帜的保险杠贴纸。我就想说，你们不知道自己是谁。他们吊死了你们的高祖父。而你们的保险杠上还贴着他们的旗帜。那挺有意思。
So we invent a fake history for ourselves that doesn't deal with the complexities. And I think that, in some ways, that's what the South and the upper Midwest have in common is that there's a delusion at work about who we were. And that's why we have a hard time about who we are.
所以我们为自己发明了一段假历史，不处理这些复杂性。我认为，在某些方面，这就是南方和中西部上游地区的共同点：我们对自己曾经是谁存在错觉。这就是为什么我们在弄清楚自己现在是谁时感到困难。
So that the kind of self-congratulatory history that passes for heritage, it keeps us from seeing ourselves and doing better.
那种被当作遗产的自吹自擂的历史，阻碍了我们看清自己并做得更好。
One place to see fake history-- on a state flag of Minnesota. The image on the flag, the state seal, was chosen by Henry Sibley. It shows a white farmer behind a plow, tilling the soil. He's looking up to watch an Indian ride away on a horse. In the original, he's literally riding into the sunset. The Indian looks back at the white man. As far as you can tell, he's leaving willingly.
查看虚假历史的一个地方——明尼苏达州旗。旗帜上的图像，即州印，是亨利·西布利选定的。它显示一个白人农民站在犁后耕作。他抬头看着一个印第安人骑马离去。在原版中，他确实正骑向夕阳。印第安人回头看着白人。据你所知，他是自愿离开的。
John Biewen. John is the director of the audio program at the Center for Documentary Studies at Duke University. And these days, if you liked this story, you can hear others like it. He's the producer of their Peabody-nominated podcast "Scene on Radio," now in its third season. That's scene-- S-C-E-N-E on radio.
约翰·比文。约翰是杜克大学纪录片研究中心音频项目的主任。这些天，如果你喜欢这个故事，你可以听到其他类似的故事。他是他们获得皮博迪奖提名的播客《Scene on Radio》的制作人，该节目目前已播出到第三季。那个名字是Scene——S-C-E-N-E on radio。
Today's program was produced by me and Brian Reed, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollack, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Mixing today by Stowe Nelson and our technical director, Matt Tierney.
今天的节目由我和布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollack）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）共同参与。我们今天节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。今天由斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）混音，我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）。
Production help from Anna Martin, music help from Damian Graef, from Rob Geddes. Our actors today-- Jake Hart, Kobi Libii, Irma Laguerre, and John Ellison Conlee. Special thanks today to David Larsen, Tiokasin Ghosthorse, Seth Barrish, Diane Fraher, Gary Clayton Anderson, and Michelle Harris.
安娜·马丁（Anna Martin）提供了制作帮助，达米安·格拉夫（Damian Graef）和罗布·格德斯（Rob Geddes）提供了音乐帮助。我们今天的演员——杰克·哈特（Jake Hart）、科比·利比（Kobi Libii）、伊尔玛·拉格雷（Irma Laguerre）和约翰·埃里森·康利（John Ellison Conlee）。特别感谢大卫·拉森（David Larsen）、蒂奥卡辛·戈斯特霍斯（Tiokasin Ghosthorse）、赛斯·巴里什（Seth Barrish）、黛安·弗雷尔（Diane Fraher）、加里·克莱顿·安德森（Gary Clayton Anderson）和米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org-- where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org——在那里你可以完全免费收听我们超过600集的档案。 《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所分发。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. I know what you're asking-- is the secret to his vast success a combination of deception, cunning, suavish good looks, rock hard abs, millions of dollars that he stole from a Federal Reserve armored car, Brylcreem, and the ability to change into a tiny little mouse and crawl into any space at will? Is it?
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。我知道你在问什么——他巨大成功的秘诀是欺骗、狡猾、风度翩翩、摇滚硬汉腹肌、他从联邦储备局装甲车上偷来的数百万美元、发蜡，以及能随意变成一只小老鼠并爬进任何空间的能力的组合吗？是吗？
Well, I'm not going to say that. But, yes, it is.
好吧，我不会这么说。但，是的，确实是。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，会有更多《美国生活》的故事。